how's it going citizens of the reject Nation
it is John and it is Roxy stryer back once
again for a momentous occasion today we're
tackling blade pre-mcu another first time
watch how are you doing Roxy yeah are you
ready to be sharp as a blade I am ready for
more tremendous comedy like that joke right
there yeah this movie should cut like a blade
oh there you go I have a long history with
this movie in that when I was a child I begged
and pleaded my mom and dad I thought Wesley
Snipes on the poster in the calendar section
the newspaper was the absolute coolest I begged
them to take me to see blade they did and
then within like the first three minutes like
it was a bunch of blood and there was a hand
on my face and we were back in the car so
I have been waiting since 1998. but guys don't
let time pass between you and leaving a like
do that right now on the video also subscribe
hit the notification Bell follow Roxy on the
social media and check out the world girls
all right give them some love over on the
YouTubes and anywhere else fine contents are
found that's the truth leave your best blade
puns Cuts deep cut two if you want to enjoy
the full length experience everything that
doesn't make these reaction highlight reels
come join us over at patreon.com the real
rejects you can sync up with your own copy
of Blade as well as a fun time and without
further ado let's watch some blade
okay 67 came out in 98 TBT foreign for TBD
was the thing
oh snap should get bit
oh no
whoa
oh damn
this is what Stephen Dorff is most famous
from right
seeing Boondocks Saints no it's Flannery I
guess it must be he used to do those cigarette
commercials those blue cigarette commercials
I'm sure he's stoked that that's your memory
of him that's right man the big uh Stephen
Dorff fan over what are we doing here
I have a sneaking suspicion that this isn't
gonna be an actual date
yeah dang Let's Get It On that looks like
the combination of Hank Azaria and Dennis
Quaid [Music] The Bodyguard no the guy she's
bringing in here no he doesn't but I want
to yes and you good job
great establishment of the vibe I really feel
like I'm there 90s let things breathe Stanley
Stanley
oh
oh my did he eat the oh my I I think he tripping
he's trying to figure out what it is I wouldn't
put anything in my mouth to drift off me on
a club ceiling or you would that's what you're
noticing he licked it hands that's what I'm
saying like I wouldn't just lick a random
thing that whoa oh damn foreign [Laughter]
BYO blood what an amazing scene this is
do you recall this at all no we were definitely
in the car before [Laughter] yeah
oh yeah yeah Jesus
Jesus at daywalker
oh damn so it just like disintegrated
dang that doesn't look bad that bad for 19.98.
I think it looks amazing yeah
ah sweet we're gonna Jack you up make them
hurt bad yeah sure you are I kind of like
that one guy from Twilight I never saw Twilight
wow him using this Blade the sound effects
sick yeah oh [Music] that's right Zuma blade
oh how cool I saw that in the poster I thought
it was the coolest freaking thing yes
give my regards to frost whoa so they rejuvenate
or regenerate
we're still scream when they found them stapled
to a wall still juicy I need you to refrain
from using that word about a body that's crisped
I'm quoting The Mummy okay it's different
when it's a reference is it no three o'clock
I'm going to give me some distance I just
want you to come down and take a look come
on it's not a date it's always a date
just a blood sample for the pericardium
yeah let me ask you something no give rough
second thoughts about us oh God damn it man
one job look I'm trying really it's over
oh snap
[Music]
oh no
oh
[Music] so what happens to her what kind of
Vamps are these
oh
hey you three
guys like someone he's carrying a civilian
oh that was a sick pullback
whoa dude what what
yes
[Music] she's good it's a very soft tarp apparently
I think it's because she's now been bit by
the vamp yeah maybe she's extra durable
killed today reminds me of my mama thank you
with allium garlic you get a lead on him no
too bad ouch I love garlic oh hold it I don't
think I've ever seen a vampire movie where
you have time after even bit some of them
as you know the genre has grown there are
a lot of different rules about like totally
some treat it like a poison you can suck out
some of it's instantaneous I don't think I've
ever seen that how many died we don't have
an exact count we're having different oh Deacon
Frost you can come in now hey hey
my blood these people are our food not our
allies or maybe I'm just the first to say
out loud what we've all been thinking we have
existed this way for thousands of years
born
how can you be born a vampire I guess it must
be like if your mother gets bit while you're
in the womb or something I don't know then
what's the aging process how do vampires procreate
yeah I love natural shows or movies make rules
like I love to know the lore like what works
in this universe yeah
essence of garlic give it to me I want it
so far the garlic and the silver stuff is
pretty cool very like classic Vamp yeah but
updated in a cool 90s way Whistler says I'm
building up a resistance to the Sarah yeah
I figured that might happen super garlic garlic
sauce truffle garlic so your belief is that
the woman in the beginning was his mom he
was born a vampire yeah but he's a day Walker
yeah like there's got to be something to do
with that that makes him the day Walker
security measure not Jennifer ham was on it
I know I was gonna say ain't no hand no more
I had to increase the dose it's over 50 milligrams
now that's getting dangerous it's over nine
thousand
oh yeah so many neck injections
oh my god oh yeah he might be the hottest
guy of the 90s comment below yes
you met blade silent jumper I got my trusty
Boomerang knife here vampires they're hard
to kill they tend to regenerate and I'm supposed
to believe all this well you already met Mr
crispy at the hospital so what do you use
then Stakes crosses crosses don't lose squat
blades there we go let's get that lore vampires
are severely allergic to Silver feed them
garlic and they're going to anaphylactic shock
and of course there's always sunlight ultraviolet
rays so garlic in you does that not affect
it unless they bite you and then they go into
shock like if you ate garlic and then they
bite you yeah that's why they do the injections
goes into your blood so or does it keep them
away you guys just patch me up and sent me
on my way vampire maze silver nitrate essence
of garlic send them into shock you start getting
sensitive to Daylight fine you're thirsty
regardless of how much you had to drink and
I suggest you take that gun and use it on
yourself I think she's interna now nah or
not in a way where she has to die every time
I would get thirsty I'd be like turning these
archives are restricted to the member
the ancient texts can never be translated
now with that attitude his eyes are crazy
cool you don't need to shout but you have
to frost what are you gonna do
say it wasn't you all right you keep your
eyes open they're everywhere but it's daytime
it's like parts of it feel like New York parts
that feel like la totally I feel like she's
keeping her eyes open
she is
tattoos mean she's gonna get in anyway
oh vampire mace
no she turns her I wonder if you spray that
on somebody's not a vampire how that would
feel I'd probably think what the [__]
that why do I taste like Italian I'm sorry
whoa whoa oh hold on hold on hold on please
the front door was open
what do you say that you were kidnapped last
night ah Curtis Webb he died don't worry about
that right now okay it's gonna be fine because
you're dead
that's right they own the cops what is this
garlic yeah yeah well he said it would work
against vampires who said I was a vampire
huh nobody
how's everybody just getting into our apartment
oh a [Music] vampires and he proves himself
maybe his master not you Guillermo a vampire
cattle brand tell us what you got
what you got how do you think that we fund
this organization huh
I know this place it's a blood bank so where
were you taking it I don't know what you're
talking about go [__] yourself oh my God
that is the biggest gun I
had to find a cure for myself oh he's saying
eventually it will get you they've just like
prolonged the inevitable I guess I mean it's
yeah it's that possibility still that it could
still take hold foreign
that's right man that's a vampire mark means
that there's a safe house around here somewhere
they're vampires shows the doorman play in
the corner outdated the way they smell it's
like a bad dream they're worse things out
tonight than vampires like what me like me
that's right sick line you have an invitation
cuddle
that's how I get in places too that's right
man what list [Music]
is
in the freezer
oh this must have been a very painful shoot
when they keep watch their records politics
Finance real estate they already own half
of downtown it's the prequel the daybreakers
downtown out down
90s user interface
blade was waiting for me don't worry about
it there's no problem yeah so he's gonna turn
him though that's good right I think he's
just gonna drink oh I don't think he's gonna
turn now no he's not gonna kill him
yeah that's what I asked for if I let you
suck my tongue would you thank me
what is this must be that the record I've
never seen an image of this what's that oh
it's nothing it's routine research
oh
oh no Baron harkonin prophecy I'm not really
sure
[Music] foreign [Music]
[Music]
you are not good at this large vampire monstrosity
Jabba The Vampire yeah Java lamp
the pages from the book of rivers was a vampire
Bible vampable
oh
shots like this always make me dizzy don't
you remember me uh whoa nice nice all the
roundhouse kicks
yeah if a little kid attacked you would you
beat them up I mean like a kid of that age
I guess I'd have to retaliate somehow I don't
know that's a great question what are the
ethics how old does your kid have to be oh
take my arm man remember
oh play piano again it's weirder than mine
oh yeah
come to think of a blade I owe you one
I'm expecting company [Music] [Laughter] oh
damn
is it a bad time
great line dude whistler's a g hey [Music]
I was gonna say how many pages of the vampire
Bible are left
whoa
CGI fire
oh boy
[Music]
oh no
come on yes
whoa
[Music] [Laughter]
ah the whole time face oh my God damn the
train stops for no one and then no words clearly
yes
dude she's a hematologist
how often in real life do people get neck
shots or is that just a movie thing I've never
seen it you're one of them aren't you no I'm
your worst nightmare you have a lot of veins
there though that was a sick sequence again
there's a lot of sex sequences Blade's mother
was attacked by a vampire while she was pregnant
and he's got their strength this time tomorrow
all those wounds of his will be healed damn
he also inherited their thirst yeah I was
wondering about that time's running out his
body's starting to reject it so far all my
efforts to find a cure of fail
baddest ass I had a family once wife two daughters
then a Drifter Came Calling one evening tried
to make me decide which order they die in
oh we killed as many of them as we can find
but it's getting worse because of frost if
something happened in the vampire ranks and
it staked my life that son of a at the center
of it I'm just confused because we established
that all the other most the vampires were
born vampires yeah you know what I mean so
why can't they day walk like he can I guess
maybe vampires can just procreate yeah maybe
that yeah that's totally what it is thank
you [Music] morning whoa when was the last
time you stopped to appreciate a good Sunrise
oh that's right you were born of vampire so
you never had the pleasure have you damn you're
never going to be a pureblatt hold them you
will never rule out
oh dude take this fangs
wow wow
[Music]
damn there we go 90s fire yeah
must be some good ass foundation they got
I'm
[Laughter] cool a lot of weapons are created
on the way to trying to find cures for things
do you think they're in love deep down I'm
just a little tight you know
oh
vanish wouldn't want our little friend here
to wind up on the back of a milk cart now
oh my God I have fangs and claws are retractable
you think the humans will ever accept a half
breed like you they can't they're afraid of
you you're an animal you're a maniac I don't
think that a freak crazy that the sunblock
works I know I want you with us
oh dang you're nothing to me but another dead
vampire yep you're an idiot you know that
nope you're gonna wish they never cut you
from your mother's womb
whoa
whoa catch her oh fine oh
dang bus ain't even stopped bust didn't even
slow down we have to treat her with gene therapy
vampires love to like yeah I needed to draw
you out yeah they always just be running around
between things
I said get out of here oh no if you kill Whistler
whoo [Music]
whoa whoa whoa do you think
we need your blade yeah we need like a blade
signal maybe like a light with a a bat I got
it
oh boy looks like some jigsaw [__]
oh no oh no yeah Frost is trying to trigger
up Vampire Apocalypse vampire God he's trying
to resurrect the earth a key she needs your
blood of course that's why he wants you alive
oh your girl's working on the Cure now walk
away oh this is devastating yeah I loved Whistler
she's making the cure just hang tight
uh by the time you watch this your friend
Whistler should be dead
it's a good thing he played that afterwards
I think that's why they give him cancer so
that we were like okay he was gonna go anyway
yeah
cast of the Silver Bullet yeah you gotta be
prepped for everything
stack them up locked and loaded let's go I
was gonna say this is the most like somber
take on a gearing up Montage yeah he's like
getting a Zenon almost the sound the music
this is not like let's [__] go this is
like I guess we gotta do this bite me I'll
just kill myself there is no cure baby there
is once human
vampires like you aren't a species you just
infected a virus a sexually transmitted I'll
tell you what we are assistant the blood God's
coming and after tonight you people of in
history anyone caught in his path will instantly
be turned it won't matter who's pure blood
and who's not how you gonna kill the whole
world this does give half blood Vibes it's
like sad yeah I do feel he's the day but I
do feel bad that people keep [__] on him
for not being pure blood it's like you kind
of got it yeah you kind of get where his bitterness
comes from and I'm like I don't know why go
to the bother of turning people if you're
gonna be this way right
yes come on come on ride your bike in the
house
let's pray in man why am I hearing gunfire
huh did I tell anybody to start shooting I
need him alive no assume it's not oh shy is
sick Sin City baby yeah and Terminator
Vamp taser
wow whoa whoa
[Music]
lumpy potatoes oh my god do you like your
potatoes mashed like I'm pulverized pureed
and otherwise that was crazy
thank you this yeah every time hey man gotta
get the most out of these tell me the 90s
without telling me we're in the 90s
no but you died I came back Eric and Deacon
welcomed me into his arms no
oh damn it I should have seen that coming
you spent your whole life looking for the
vampire who bit your mother here I am oh uh
what a bastard maybe when we get out of this
I'll take that Miracle cue of yours there's
one catch if it works you'll be completely
human uh why would you want to be human just
to avoid it sucking a little blood
oh it looks even better in person making
totally why isn't his mom thinking about him
indoctrinated to the cause this made me so
sad but still is mommy mommy mom mama
safety's off what do we have here the precious
serum how long has it been since your shadow
uh oh what's it feel like try it try some
you might like it I don't think you'll be
needing these anymore yes he does you should
have listened to your blood say what you want
what you want but I promise you you'll be
dead by Dawn Evil Dead too evil does to me
I'd like you to meet an old friend of yours
oh oh no no she's resourceful she'll get out
of there
can we talk about us I never thought I would
see you again tell me Karen do you ever have
second thoughts about us one track mind damn
dude wow yes he's gonna grab her legs
yeah very striking [Music]
it's good they found one just his size too
yeah I'd look a real idiot in there not even
filling it out tiptoes try to understand Eric
your mother died a long time ago it's time
for an edible complex cute and I've enjoyed
it how about you I don't like this moment
a little sooner or later The Thirst always
wins uncomfortable given to The Thirst I was
a literal thirst trap just yeah are they gonna
drain him in that thing
Iron Maiden
new new ouch
like it does look like an Iron Maiden just
like less spikes oh geez oh bring the elevator
up oh dude
[Applause]
yes yeah go save them you ain't no damn Damsel
in Distress neither is he but he is in distress
right now but he's a damselves go help even
if Frost is right I really think he cares
about you you you're gonna die it's like the
rest of us
oh I can't say stuff like that out loud man
she only has a temper no self-control wait
is she gonna let him eat her oh maybe tonight
the age of man comes to an end we're going
to be gods of course yeah this is the dawning
of the age of LA magara are you bleeding today
we got no choice gotta try it right now I
want you to take some
of my blood [Music] oh this is me sexy foreign
ritual oh
okay that's enough that's enough oh no
well they are shooting this like a sex scene
I know like be a sex scene without being a
sex scene
oh
they could have worked on their blood a little
bit
oh no mom
oh [__]
[Music] I like the little skeleton flashes
wow not bad I must release you
dang cool
wow wow that looks crazy
whoa dang shot this pretty smart for those
effects
Dexter
I got two new hands blade I don't know which
one to use to kill you with
we only got one head yeah you got your glasses
back don't take a man's glasses
oh yeah now we talk and now you're cooking
with gas oh
damn dude
yes the girl fights the other girl as God
intended obviously it's about to be a what
girl for you oh I'm Really Gonna enjoy this
now no why is she devil
never get sold did you enjoy it honey was
that good for you was it as good for you as
it was for me
their breakdown's fighting whoa
ouch
blade blade blade blade
it
love that little
where's our girl she's up there somewhere
depleted whoa
whoa
the last few blood damn
yeah any mouth what the [__] yes he did
it's an interesting call huh wow
magra must be a lady God
flipping
none of that affects him anymore so what are
we gonna do It's gotta be the garlic and the
silver yeah he's gonna have to find the world's
largest clove of garlic and put it up his
butt
thank you nice shot yeah boy you knew that
was a great usage of that excellent work that's
a cool yeah device
is that him
whoa whoa whoa whoa come out some [__]
are always trying to ice skate uphill I never
heard that I've never heard that one but I
like it yes
oh my God he looks insane right now yeah some
[__] are always trying to ice skate uphill
that's right I love when it does this [__]
[Music] oh it's like Street trash or something
like a bunch of grapes trying to ice skate
uphill
but like is she okay I guess you've seen enough
[__] now that she can hang out a few more
hours before getting that cure again or maybe
it's different because he's the day Walker
I don't know if it will work because she already
had taken it what happens when the day Walker
feeds on you there's still a war going on
and I have a job to do you want to help make
me a better
okay still needs his power he is right there
is a job to do
please
Alex surprises too
[Laughter] there you go there you go
I was like the equivalent scene right there
that was wicked [Music] it's like very obvious
why this movie gets as much love as it does
yeah okay so Donald Logue was the the one
guy damn that went hard not bad not bad not
bad at all that was legitimate eight-year-old
me is so psyched right now but do you think
it's not bad or you think it's really good
no that was really good I thought that was
super [__] solid yeah yeah yeah yeah no
no don't don't mistake the tone the tone of
not bad not the words not bad it was really
good like the first of all he is so badass
dude Wesley Snipes all day like I this makes
me wish that they would somehow Multiverse
him in Just Right totally he's so sexy he's
so badass he's so believable he's a great
actor he delivers those Stone Cold lines it's
like him and Keon who both have that thing
down you know and then and he'd be throwing
down on the it looked like he was throwing
down on a lot of those stunts if not most
all of them could I have used more of a love
story you know I could have do I want to see
them like passionately suck face and just
like I would have I would have been here for
it I'm so happy I saved you yeah I did want
to see that I did but other than that it's
Perfection you want the romance novel cut
I do the the um uh what was Stephen dorff's
character's name from Sunshine Frost yeah
the opposite Sunshine Frost was Frost was
spooky [__] he was he was crazy good on
you Stephen Dorff yeah he had that perfect
he had a good balance of like yeah being like
the petulant younger guy who nobody takes
seriously but not like an annoying like he
had the right balance where I'm not like how
did this guy get to where he is right you
could see it yeah it was Friday sometimes
yeah he's like just the right amount of a
brat like not too much to where I'm like I
don't believe this guy but enough that I'm
like yeah I see why you're sort of alienated
from everybody and everyone's always being
like oh you have blood you know you you're
not one of us real vampires man so like you
know I got where his character came from and
I thought yeah just like because of what vampire
lore is and and this sort of iconography that
you've come to expect I feel like yeah he
embodies that sort of like you know he's got
his sexy fluid thing he's a little bit Manic
and crazed but also you know he's he's just
like a hot young guy man totally the thing
that was cool too though is that all the vampires
are problematic even the one that he kills
by looking at the sunshine you know like that
guy's obsessed with pure Bloods yeah I know
someone else who is obsessed with pure blood
you know like you never want like it's not
like some of the vampires were good some of
them are bad it's just pretty much for the
most part it's just blade is good yeah all
the other vampires we see are bad varying
degrees of bad and and have different motivations
right like there's the ones that want all
the vampires to be pure purebred which is
like they're born a vampire and then there's
the Half-Blood vampires that want vampires
to take over the world and get rid of the
humans it's like different degrees and variations
and steps down and whatnot yeah absolutely
and I like the way that they unfolded their
lore I mean sometimes you know when you're
like in the heat of a reaction and stuff like
that you got to kind of like collect and keep
all the details straight but I thought that
they did nicely not to like do too much Exposition
dumping while also kind of letting you get
the hang of like okay so these vampires can
regenerate and okay so there is a difference
between pure blood and turned vampires oh
snap Gary ton of Cliff did a bunch of the
makeup effects I got to uh do a little uh
I got to do a little shoot with him once that's
cool what'd you do I used to work uh for fangoria
back in the day and we did a show uh called
blood and guts that was later retitled blood
Works where Scott Ian from Anthrax uh would
go to different effects houses and they would
demonstrate an effect and then do it on Scott
and uh yeah we got to go to Gary tunnel Cliff's
place that's cool at one point in time that's
cool that's a cool dude uh did you feel like
it was a little some parts dragged a little
bit or you've thought it was good pace for
the most part I thought it was it was pretty
well paced I mean it this is this is like
a two-hour movie and so part of me I'm fascinated
by this because this came at a time before
what the superhero movie the comic book movie
Etc that we know now came into full form so
I feel like this did like take its time at
moments to slow down a little bit and to have
like little character beats and stuff uh I
didn't feel like it ever really dragged that
much but there were times where I was like
okay so we're slowing down to breathe a little
bit and and most of the time when I would
notice that it was during a scene that I liked
I mean I usually I preferred it more when
it's like okay we're getting to know Whistler
a little bit more okay here's an intimate
moment between Karen and blade or something
like that but uh but yeah I mean it definitely
has sort of a different approach to the pace
in that regard and it feels like something
a bit more out of the 90s like if you said
to me that you you know were like oh you could
tighten this up by like 10 or 15 minutes like
I yeah I would like argue you against that
but at the same time I'm not sitting here
going like man like certain parts of the like
I liked living in the world still I'm with
you how did you feel that this compares to
other vampire pieces like taking out the superhero
component of this or whatever you want to
call or the the uh comic book aspect of this
like just focusing on the supernatural do
you feel like this is a good vampire movie
do you like the way that they dealt with the
vampires and like what their different looks
were how they die how they what powers they
have what hurts them yeah I like this the
lore in the society they set up quite a a
bit actually I mean yeah you I mean it's part
parts of it are obviously borrowing from the
classics but you know you have this underground
CD World of Vampires that secretly controls
everything like it did almost remind me of
something that could come like you know a
certain I forget how far in the future something
like daybreakers is set but you know it's
like they got their hands on the cops and
they got you know clearly all these different
Enterprises and stuff like that and the shadowy
cabal of you know the top vampire families
or whatever that is like I thought all that
stuff was cool and then the ultimate end game
of like we have this vampire Bible and there's
a prophecy and we have to do this Blood ritual
to bring back you know this ancient Spirit
to you know help us you know take over the
world and or destroy it uh yeah like I thought
it was nice in that regard and also then bringing
in elements like okay so silver and garlic
those things work stuff like holy water and
Crosses doesn't so much so yeah I like that
they said that they're like some of that BS
and it's like oh yeah it's like you know not
that I'm always sitting here going like remove
the religious aspect but like that makes sense
to me it's like okay so like this world yeah
the religious or the more sort of like faith-based
uh remedies or or weapons are not going to
be effective here but there are certain like
science-based things that they use and even
the thing with trying to figure out the Cure
like that can be you know kind of kind of
a silly thing in movies and and certainly
here I guess it does sort of get resolved
kind of in that one moment where she's like
well if I you know do this the way we would
approach this other you know disease that
I'm aware of you know I can kind of make at
least a cure for people who have been bit
and transformed after the fact and uh but
even that you know I thought was I like that
they took the time to differentiate like you
know I don't think it would work on like a
purebred vampire or maybe somebody who's been
gone way too long because that was another
thing too when his mom came back I was like
oh no are they gonna do a thing where they
like try to cure her from this yeah or something
like that and uh and yeah like I liked the
The Temper the tempering of that I guess but
she didn't know Humanity left in her oh she
did now that you've seen this what would you
want say your dream doing the blade movie
that's coming out now would you want it to
be a sequel to this would you want it to be
a remake of this would you want them like
what was it that you would want that's an
excellent question because I think this like
you know watching this in the here and now
where uh obviously you have everything to
compare it to I'm like this is kind of what
I would have wanted from a blade I know I
know it's like weird that we're watching this
now because now it's like what do I what other
thing do I need yeah and like this also had
I I appreciate this too because this is 1998
you have a lot of obviously practical gags
but a fair amount of CG gags as well and so
all I can imagine at this moment is like okay
so the effects will look more smooth and we're
in a time and place where I my main concern
with the new blade is like this did so many
things a with blood gags but also like you
had the big old giant like Glutton creature
and you had like little things like that that
I'd never even seen that image before I was
like what is this dude and then you had like
the the anti-serum that like you know makes
them all like warp out blow up and and yeah
like it is so kind of pulpy and wild and I
am it makes me a little bit wary just because
I'm like I don't know how this I'm sure there's
a possible way to do it there's always a way
to do it but uh yeah going nobody knows yet
if it'll be a PG-13 but that's kind of like
the worst case scenario that you would expect
for you know an MCU bummer itself for PG-13
the way that the character needs yeah but
who knows they might be able to make that
work um it's just such a dark like vampire
in Vampire me fiction media Etc lore is all
kind of carnal and and sensuous and bloody
so yeah I mean you they've made various PG-13
Vamp movies but I feel like to really yeah
get the oomph that you want because too I
mean you know I think these comic book universes
have an interesting interplay as well between
you know like DC has a Constantine where you're
going into like magic and the more hellish
side of the world and it's demons and creatures
and it's sort of removed even though it makes
sense that they would co-exist in a world
with like alien super beings or people transformed
in lab accidents it still feels like a a sort
of separate side of the world too and I feel
like this would occupy that kind of space
in a place like the MCU and so yeah it's like
almost like elseworlds MCU like like a little
bit or just like their vertigo whatever their
version of that is because that DC's is like
Constantine Swamp Thing that you know that's
they're like because they but they even still
like coincide with the other characters like
at least watching some of the animated movies
it's like the first in the DC AMU continuity
they introduce you to Constantine and etragon
and all those characters via the Justice League
at first so it's like I could see the way
that blade could you know intersect with the
rest of the MCU I mean like I would be super
down for an else world as well because I feel
like you know oftentimes people Echo the idea
of like when you're less burdened by interconnectivity
things can shine a little brighter but yeah
it's mostly about a sensibility it's like
watching this I could imagine you know a a
modern you know read Redux of blade or the
new take on blade being maybe a little tighter
in terms of that pace but again I thought
it was I I liked this this was Pace like more
of an actual movie and then you had these
moments with these like crazy speed ramp gags
and stuff like that they put a lot of Personality
into how the world came across you know yeah
I like that you just use the term personality
because it really did like the way this looked
and sounded had a it was a for lack of better
words just to be as Millennial as possible
for a second it was a total [__] Vibe
yeah it's a total Vibe like I knew exactly
what they were trying to do what do you think
about where we rented this it says that it's
science fiction suspense compelling downbeat
I mean I love the way they they categorize
these descriptors now I mean yeah certainly
science fiction I mean there's some suspension
like this actually had some tension I thought
you know even in moments where you can imagine
in your movie math brain how certain things
will work out or not like I still found myself
getting caught up in things and I thought
the impact of certain uh just perilous moments
or deaths like the whole thing with Whistler
like I really came to like that character
a lot and then when he died yeah I was sitting
there kind of in the bargaining of like no
no there's got to be a way like damn it but
you know ultimately and it gives him the gun
man yeah and then I'm like did they did he
like run back there to grab it yeah but what
would you want from an MCU blade having seen
this now I just don't really know first of
all who could do this as well as Wesley did
it I mean I like mahershal Ali is great and
I have faith in him but also Wednesday Snipes
like because there is like a sort of grind
houseness about this too and I feel like Wesley
Snipes is like a great call to bring that
flavor to life yeah it's it's nothing against
anybody it's just like this was he's so great
in this Wesley's so great in this that it's
like I'm not looking for something different
but we need to be looking for something different
because we don't want martial law to just
do a Wesley yeah you know so like yeah what's
going to be the spin and then I I don't know
like is it does blade and the girl that I
wanted to see him get on with do they do they
have a pure blood kid like like do they try
to teach them what happens you know the the
day Walker yeah it creates with a human well
she's not well I guess she is she could be
a half blood though he just sucked on her
again I know but she can curious I think they
said she can cure herself again
um but no I can't tell what the actual story
I would need to be and I I haven't read any
of the blade comics so I don't know like who
are who else is in our sandbox to play with
yeah so yeah but I I'm not not looking forward
to it because it's somewhat of a simple premise
and I love vampire stories well that's the
thing is I feel like yeah thinking about what
new blade could be is just sort of like I
don't know I guess it would just be a blade
movie kind of like what we just sucks but
just with new faces and I wouldn't ultimately
be upset by that because I don't know yes
you're gonna have slightly different characters
villains different storyline Etc like so I
feel like this is a solid enough blueprint
and they don't really they can tweak but they
don't really need to tweak a whole lot to
you know didn't they have a director on the
project and then they pulled them that project
has been retooled a lot they had I think the
director left I think they've gotten different
writers on it and now we have the writer strike
going on so yeah that movie is seems like
it's having a particularly bumpy journey to
fruition bummer but this was legit man I I
really yeah this is after so many years of
trying this this really uh yeah it had I think
like some of the best elements of 90s cheese
but also watching it you know so many years
removed and I'm like still holds up man totally
yeah like this doesn't feel like I have to
give it too many handicaps for being you know
of a certain time and place yeah there's like
one or two throughout where we were like oh
where'd the sound go there like okay the way
that looks but for the most part it just was
really solid for a 98 Super solid yeah it
just feels like you know the nightlife is
really Vivid and the effect like I thought
they smartly shot most of the effects so that
yeah like even when the CG is not like up
to Modern standards the scene still works
and it's like you know those skeleton you
know flying skeleton demon monsters that come
out at the end yeah a little sick looking
they don't look photo real but they look great
yeah like like as they're coming out of the
the people's mouths yeah like for how they
chose to shoot that and light that and how
they you know animated and captured it like
yeah I just thought this had a lot of energy
and a lot of punch it says downbeat and like
yeah it is a little dreary but I thought it
still had a pulse and it still had that kind
of I guess that's it it's like I'm interested
to see what the MCU does but I'm glad that
this had like its Edge on it because I feel
like it needs to it is the dark side so it
can't be as like I I would rather see downbeat
as the descriptor then yeah totally I think
that uh the good thing about when they do
this what I always try to remind myself the
good thing about when they do like the next
blade is that this one still exists it doesn't
take that and and put it in the trash so there
will always be this so to this too yeah yeah
it'll be interesting to see what they do with
it yeah yeah good action it's just one right
designs of this yeah no they're three three
I thought there was just one more I thought
it was blade one and two there's blade three
Blade Trinity yeah I forgot there it is a
Trilogy and the third one is called braid
Blade Trinity wow braid Trinity and one of
them has like Ryan Reynolds and I think one
of them was in fact I think I think I've heard
it said that the Ryan Reynolds one is is like
he's the one good part of that Sequel and
I think maybe like Blade Two or something
people like it's kind of underrated and I
think like Guillermo del toross no no I mean
Blade Trinity is definitely a thing does he
make it out alive of Blade Trinity I don't
know any of the blades I saw two and three
but never the first no no you know but uh
I mean I would love to I would love to continue
the journey I would love to see how this world
evolves and how they you know because this
was also Yeah a different time where like
franchising things wasn't quite as streamlined
obviously as it is now um but this is a world
that I would like be totally psyched to come
back to I'd be totally psyched to see a different
take on a different city like I love the way
they captured the city and there's just so
much to do with a world like this and I mean
not that other vampire stories haven't explored
that stuff but you know it's like with the
different casts of vampires pure blood turned
this daywalker situation seems like there's
a lot you could explore with that definitely
and they put like a lot of moving Parts which
is good not too many but a lot that we could
explore yeah and like these other like more
feral looking creatures like the guy the you
know lab the nurse the lab tech the guy she's
working with who she doesn't want to talk
about their past relationship like it seemed
like they'd been like starving him and he
was turning into like a sickly sort of creature
um so yeah it's like one of those movies where
I feel like it's it's rounded for the story
they're telling but it also just hints at
more stuff you know beyond the periphery um
so yeah I don't know I thought the cast did
really really nice job overall I'm with you
uh Wesley Snipes freaking killing it whoever
uh what is her name who played Karen I thought
she did a good job she was excellent and uh
and that was like a nice um you know it's
like I was rooting for that love story and
I I am often these days being like I want
a little more like actual romance in these
things big make out at the end I wanted yeah
your face sucks I wanted a little little like
ending vampire orgy Ivy that's the thing is
like you know vampire stuff is like trademark
sexy I know so I know I watched all Vampire
Diaries and The Originals listen I watched
all of Buffy she was a Slayer that's true
this is really good but you know that was
a soap opera that brought back the The Craze
of vampires and theme song was Tainted Love
oh my baby returned here alone which is a
cover I never knew Soft Cell did not write
that song oh who did oh I'd have to dig back
I used to know this reach deep but yeah it's
like one of those songs that was like written
for I think it was written for like a female
singer or something like that like you know
a couple decades prior and then yeah and then
they did the cover I never saw any of the
Twilight movies ah I've seen one or two I
never saw them uh I feel like did this do
vampires better
don't go to Twilight if what you want is vampire
lore what's your favorite vampire movie oh
that's a great question oh I would have to
think um
Jesus I always lean towards like classic stuff
like I always I've watched like Nosferatu
every every year I mean I I have it could
be better in places but I really like daybreakers
like when the when the vampire craze was really
going down that was a movie I was uh quite
enamored by there's one called a girl walks
home alone at night that's pretty cool do
you like of werewolf zombies vampires what's
your jam a root for werewolf because they're
like underdone I feel like um ah I probably
find I probably would say vampire just pound
for pound I feel like there's the I mean there
are a lot of great zombie movies um there
it seems like as I'm trying to think there's
more vampire TV shows but I feel like there's
more zombie movies than vampire movies is
that wrong there's I mean I would be fascinated
to know the answer because it does seem like
there are there there are hordes of zombie
movies as as you know innumerable as the actual
hordes within them um but I feel like vampire
is like well trodden and and goes back probably
longer uh has has greater longevity probably
than the zombie story [Music] and I haven't
seen like I haven't seen like uh Let the Right
One In which I know people love um let's see
okay um Renfield was just good oh I wanted
to see that I I uh I've heard good things
I've never seen Interview with a Vampire feel
like people are loving the TV show right now
I watched the first couple episodes it was
good yeah um I guess Nosferatu I feel like
like a like a cop-out saying that I mean what
we do in the shadows is great if you like
a movie or the show better for what we do
in the shadows yeah uh I guess probably the
movie but I like the show just as much fright
night's pretty good I haven't seen the uh
the remake of fright night but uh but yeah
From Dusk Till Dawn that's a great vampire
movie that might be a time I've missed a lot
of these a topper and you both of us have
not seen underworld Ah that's right yeah and
I feel like I think that one has both has
both vampires and uh werewolves if I'm not
mistaken uh but yeah what's your favorite
vampire movie I don't know I'm I'm you know
I'm a TV girly when it comes to a lot of these
like sure nerdy things yeah so do we count
Buffy as a vampire show yeah definitely it's
in the title I mean you know there are other
monsters but I feel like vampires are like
a Mainstay of you know that one Slayer that's
right this is good [__] man I like this
a lot I I would be thrilled to see more of
the blade universe and uh and yeah like I
just want to soak up all the Wesley Snipes
because this this does seem like one of those
instances and I don't have like the greatest
experience with blade comics but he seems
like a like a terrific choice to bring a character
like this to life and especially with how
much you can tell he's really thrown down
like you know he seems like the perfect like
action star vehicle that's also like nice
and gooey and horary and and just yeah like
the vampire nightclub and stuff like that
there's so many cool like you know little
flourishes
[Music] we've been watching good stuff together
that's a thumbs up good luck charm you got
any more stray thoughts before we skedaddle
because of the braids right man because braid
rhymes with blade that's right blade Trinity
over here oh yeah I hope I hope it watches
so we can watch the next one yeah I hope I
would love that I would love to at least watch
the the agreeable ones you know I know people
I know there's at least one that people don't
like so much but uh you know I think how bad
could it be it's with Wesley ah right yeah
totally and I mean I'm sure there are other
like crazy uh guess uh you know supporting
actors that I don't know about to surprise
us too that's crazy that's right man I I think
that's again this is like the one part of
that movie I've heard is good do you have
closing thoughts no just uh just want more
I just want you know I wanna this was vital
you know and uh I'm glad to have finally like
I said this movie has been built up over so
much time for me because of that specific
experience it's like yeah I begged and begged
we went and yeah like the second they got
into the class just I knew because I yeah
it's like okay she's mom's on the floor she
grabbed that dude's crotch blood sprinkler
and like those are the three images I remember
from my youth so having that paid off now
and I tried to actually watch it again years
later with a friend who I hadn't seen in a
long time and and we went to put it on and
just wound up talking to each other like and
not even you know engaging with any movies
so like yeah after so long this was like a
triumphant you know dunk well you did it I
didn't have to like work to enjoy this is
good quite quite delightful what did you guys
think leave us your thoughts down below be
very excited to hear what y'all think about
this and if you want us to check out any more
of the Blade franchise heading into the MCU
version and uh yeah much love to y'all check
us out on patreon if you want to get the full
experience and last but not least let's do
a page
kale Linden my dude I think we should attend
a vampire party together I think that would
be good McHale's out in uh in Sweden oh I
feel like they'd have good vampires in Sweden
yeah man I feel like the vampires in Sweden
like you know I feel like I watch a lot of
like you know American vampire movies or early
vampire movies set in America and everyone
just kind of like sleazed out all the time
like I feel like Swedish vampires would be
a little bit more poised a little bit more
genial do you think that they are sweeter
in Sweden they are they are the Swedish
Mikhail is the sweetest of all yeah he's a
he is a sugary uh delightful Swedish Fish
he's a Swedish Fish I love Swedish fish do
they come from Sweden Mikhail let us know
the history of Swedish Fish and let us know
how many Americans ask you about this yeah
because they're very popular here are they
just called fish in Sweden let us know and
uh yeah hope you're out there doing well we
appreciate you being you were your support
of this patreon is goes back so far it's like
you are you know like part of an ancient lineage
of super sexy pjx oh so you know damn yeah
so if ever we need to do some kind of blood
ritual to awaken like the prime ordeal reject
of the nation you know you will be the high
priest for that I think it's a good combo
sweet and sexy
sexy Mikhail we love you